those kinds of like competitive games i
[ __ ] love right like
i don't want to say the word party games
right but like i mean they are i mean
they are party games like that's why i
[ __ ] love about party games is that
yeah you'll get people who are [ __ ]
salty and it is
pvp technically but at the end of the
day it's [ __ ] whatever
it's a [ __ ] mario kart game right
what do you think about people throwing
their controllers joey huh
controllers i mean i've done it before
actually actually yeah i've done it in
smash remember
did you really yeah i think it's so
cringey
no matter how angry i get i'll be like
but not you yeah yeah
okay to be fair i only did it once she
looks expensive [ __ ] joy-con so i'm
throwing those things
oh no no no no no i threw like the
really cheap [ __ ] like gamecube
controller
oh there's just like 15 bucks it's like
the buzzer one it's like even if i break
this i can buy another one it's fine
but the the like pro control that
youtuber money here
pro controller i would never and that's
it's too much of an expensive like oh my
god seeing like smash compilations of
like
people just absolutely just shocking
their control
i do love watching smash tournament rage
moments oh it's so funny
i'm like dude it's a party game like
just chill yeah but like i was about to
ask what do you think about party games
i mean do you see smash
as a party game yeah you're gonna piss
so many people
dude sakurai himself said it was a party
game so it's a [ __ ] party game all
right
it's a party game that can be played
it's a party game that it can also be
complete imagine like musical chairs if
there was a pro league yeah
yeah yes
i can't wait for the soul in the
comments man i cannot wait for the soul
in the comments
i mean look it's like i look it's not
i'm not saying that
you know smash is not a competitive game
like it absolutely is i [ __ ] love
watching the competitive scene of smash
bros
yeah but but it's a competitive game
that can also be a party game
you know like again like if you said for
example
right if [ __ ] mario kart had like a
pro league then yeah it could probably
be a competitive game
but it doesn't why doesn't it though why
why okay here's here's why
i've never understand why does why how
did smash get
so competitive as opposed to basically
like every other nintendo game i think
because a lot of them are like too
random
like my heart has way too many random
aspects right like
that's why i like smash like smash
competitive is like no items final
destination
they literally nuke all the
randomization right right
so even the stages they can't move right
like yeah so the only like i think the
only way that something like mario kart
could ever be competitive is it just
no items of course no items and
everyone's baby parts
of course no items everyone's everyone's
in the same character with the same card
that'd be so [ __ ] boring yeah and
that's the only reason why right yeah
yeah but like again like you know i'm
sure there's lots of
party games out there that could very
easily be considered competitive games
guitar hero yeah i mean that's just the
way that should go into rhythm games
right
there wasn't it was actually competitive
yeah that's what i thought that's that's
that's why rhythm games could very
easily be competitive games but they're
not
because there's like no real league for
it but i reckon the only reason why
smash became a competitive game is
because of all the [ __ ] street
fighter games
yeah i feel like also it's it's just a
nice spectator sport as well
because i feel like with with
competitive with competitive games
if there's going to be a league for it
it's got to be interesting to watch
i'd say i feel like that's why league is
the biggest esport because i while i
hardly ever play league anymore i still
[ __ ] watch it every year because
it is a really fun game to watch as
opposed to because there's so much going
on
yeah yeah exactly and it's it feels like
it was it feels like it's a game that's
designed to also be viewed as well from
a third person
from a third person perspective i mean i
used to when overwatch was doing the pro
league
my friends used to watch it but i used
to watch it and i'm like what the [ __ ]
is this i play this game and there's way
too much going on the
teams can't possibly describe what's
going because all the action happened
so fast and it's six different people
doing six different things
it's normally if it's a team fight it's
still like you can still
tell people what's going on yeah because
it's because it's because of the
top-down view as opposed to overwatch
you're just like first person
you're getting nauseating yeah [ __ ]
be following tracer tracer zooms back
and then they're switching to the next
guy and switching again it's like
bro just [ __ ] me like and also i feel
that
because of the length of league it's
something you can sit down and enjoy and
like i think the one reason i've really
got into fighting games is that
normally when i'm watching i mean
esports is what i'm saying when i'm
watching the esports
uh i normally only watch like the finals
because i can kind of follow what's
going on it's like the semis then the
finals
it's really easy to follow along but
when the group stages going on it's like
all right who's this guy and by the time
i finish googling him the next guy's on
fighting and i'm like all right well
okay um who's this guy and then the
fight maybe at one of the watches over
in three minutes and it's like okay well
i guess uh
yeah i guess that's it i guess all the
fights are over okay [ __ ] like
league is quite a long thing and they've
got a really good system with the league
where it plays like what like two
there's like every league plays every
day now like yeah like alternates on on
season
i mean it's crazy it's set up literally
like a football
yeah it's it's it's it's way it's way
more like just a football
you know like a traditional sports now
where you can like kind of like jump in
and jump out and see familiar faces and
kind of like familiar brands every time
yeah and i feel like that's kind of
helped
it's like the esports scene in league is
just it just seems to keep growing every
year which is
[ __ ] insane to me that it's like
[ __ ] 10 11 years old now how old is
league
10. yeah and it's still like growing
each year internationally which
shows esports yeah these forces which
which shows the power but
like talk like i enjoy watching fighting
games as well
like i like the only but the only time i
ever get into it is during like evo or
like the big whenever it's like oh why
is there a million views on twitch oh
it's evil
yeah like i don't go around like [ __ ]
looking for like you know local cons
doing
you know smash tournaments like i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna watch those live but
you know but yeah like evo and [ __ ]
you know those big smash tournaments are
[ __ ] fun to watch